[Musik]
vor zehn jahren ist ein buch zum
internationalen bestseller geworden dass
anfangs niemand zu recht im blick hatte
es heißt der hase mit den bernstein
augen von edmund de waal eine anderthalb
jahrhunderte umspannende weltgeschichte
anhand einer familiengeschichte
die wiederum erzählt anhand einer
sammlung kleinster japanischer
schnitzkunst werke so genannter mit
zucker jetzt hat edmund de waal einen
neuen roman veröffentlicht kam mondo
heißt er dem untertitel zufolge eine
familiengeschichte in briefen zugleich
die geschichte einer pariser straße der
rüde muss so in der besagte hase mit den
bernsteinen augen zusammen mit den
anderen nicht zu lange aufbewahrt wurde
wir sprechen über kommando die
hintergründe die qualität dieses romans
und über seinen autor edmund de waal mit
andreas platthaus literatur chef der vz
vielen dank dass sie zeit für uns haben
lieber herr platthaus es ist mir ein
großes vergnügen kommando wessen namen
trägt der neue roman von edmund de waal
kommando ist ein familienname natürlich
auch eine einzelperson denn briefe
schreibt man im regelfall nicht an ganze
familien die einzelperson an die edmund
de waal die briefe seines sagen wir doch
ruhig roman hier richtet ist müßig
amondo ein jüdischer reicher
kunstsammler der von der wende des 19
zwanzigste jahrhundert und die familie
kommando ist in gewisser weise das
äquivalent in paris zur familie von
edmund de waal dann muss man fairerweise
sagen die wahl klingt nicht besonders
französisch als familienname und das ist
auch nicht so der wahl ist der name des
niederländischen großvaters des autors
aber seine großmutter war eine geborene
france das klingt jetzt auch nicht
besonders französisch was daran liegt
dass das eine familie war die aus odessa
als große jüdische handels dynastie nach
paris umgezogen ist und dort immens
reich geworden ist und wahnsinnig viel
kunst gesammelt hat und ziemlich genau
das gleiche gilt für die kommandos nur
dass die aus konstantinopel gekommen
sind stadt aus und deshalb und diese
großen jüdischen familien die in paris
ist ahnen dass jäckle und dann des
frühen zwanzigsten jahrhundert sich als
kunstsammler betätigt haben waren
natürlich alle miteinander bekannt auch
alle unmittelbar konkurrenten in
natürlich dem kampf um die wichtigsten
kunstwerke sie haben alle
impressionisten gesammelt sie waren alle
fans von japanischer kunst sie haben
aber auch die klassische französische
kunst gesammelt sie waren konkurrenten
im sammeln aber gleichzeitig auch wieder
geistes genossen in ihrer begeisterung
für all diese kunst und darum gab es
vielfältige freundschaftliche und auch
familiäre beziehungen
die haben untereinander geheiratet und
die familie yves rossy ist über eine
heirat auch mit der familie kommando
verwandt und dementsprechend richtet
edmund de waal seine briefe an einen
mann die nanny kennengelernt hatte war
das jahr 1964 louis de camargo ist 1936
gestorben aber jemanden der mit seinem
urgroßvater ganz eng befreundet war und
jemand der eine ganz ähnliche
familiengeschichte aufzuweisen hat wie
de france und damit eben auch edmund de
waal und aus dieser vertrautheit über
ein jahrhundert hinweg entstehen diese
briefe das klingt jetzt weltumspannend
und weitläufig erstmal aber es geht um
eine ziemlich ähnlichen nachbarschaft im
hasen mit den bernstein augen wie auch
jetzt in kommando es geht um das hotel
yves rossy zum beispiel die der
familiensitz zehn häuser die rüde muss
so hinauf und was hat es mit dieser
stimmten nachbarschaft auf sich das ist
ein viertel in paris in der nähe des
parc monceau das spät im neunzehnten
jahrhundert erschlossen worden ist im
zuge der haus manchen umgestaltungen von
paris und von anfang an gestaltet wurde
als ein nennen wir es luxusviertel in
der stadt da sind die reichen hingezogen
und die reichen waren im ausgehenden
neunzehnten jahrhundert auch einige
jüdische familien die sich dort
etabliert hatten die dann das
französische bürgerrecht natürlich
bekommen haben die staatsbürgerschaft
angenommen haben und darum mit fug und
recht franzosen genannt werden konnten
und unglaublich stolz auf ihre
französische staatsbürgerschaft waren
das ist etwas was beispielsweise sowohl
im hasen mit dem bernstein augen wie
auch jetzt in kommando immer wieder
deutlich wird was für eine immense
identifikation zwischen diesen reichen
jüdischen familien aus ganz europa und
ihrer neuen heimat frankreich existierte
dass die sich mit allen mit mit haut und
haaren eigentlich als franzosen
begriffen und das tragische ist dass
dieses
integrieren dieser jüdischen familien
die französische gesellschaft die leider
gottes fast überall in europa im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert gescheitert ist
erstmal vom logistik amondo der mann den
die briefe gerichtet ist seinen einzigen
sohn im ersten weltkrieg der von den
deutschen mit seinem flugzeug
abgeschossen wurde und dabei staub und
dann muss man leider gottes fast schon
sagen starb musste kamen dort 36 gerade
noch so rechtzeitig dass er dem
deutschen einmarsch nicht miterlebte
denn alle übrigen familienmitglieder
mit ausnahme der von ihm geschiedenen
frau sind von den nazis ermordet worden
das heißt diese jüdischen sammler
dynastien sind soweit sie nicht
irgendwelche verwandten im sicheren
ausland hatten sprich in großbritannien
wie die familie die wahl zu diesem
zeitpunkt sind umgebracht worden und das
was sie für den staat frankreich
geleistet haben ist ihnen unter der
besetzung in deutschland weiß gott nicht
gedankt worden diese leute wurden
genauso natürlich vor den deutschen aber
auch von den französischen handlangern
der deutschen verfolgt und denen
ausgeliefert und das ist der zentrale
gegenstand des buches kommando wie der
versuch einer assimilation in einer
integration in eine andere gesellschaft
gescheitert ist wie knüpft also kann
monto an an den hasen mit den bernstein
augen und vor allem was ist das neue im
kosmos von edmund de waal damit sprechen
sie den wunden punkt an es gibt für mich
ein bisschen zu wenig neues in diesem
buch es ist sehr faszinierend zu lesen
und die wahl ist ein ganz
ausgezeichneter stil ist über die
deutsche übersetzung könnte man in 23
punkten streiten vor allem hätte das
lektorat ein paar sehr ärgerliche rechts
schreibe fehler ausmerzen können aber
geschenkt der tonfall ist ist trotz
allem sehr angenehm nur wenn man den
hasen mit den bernstein augen gelesen
hat dann kennt man schon recht viel von
dem was in kommando eine rolle spielt
denn da wurde auch natürlich schon über
diese großartige kultur der pariser
reichen jüdischen familien geschrieben
am beispiel der yves rossy es aber
natürlich kamen die kommandos da auch
schon vor und die rothschilds und wie
sie alle heißen haben die damals in
paris kunst sammelten und die
gesellschaft projekten und das macht
jetzt nicht den hauptteil des neuen
buches aus aber es gibt immer wieder
natürlich momente in denen edmund de
waal auch dinge rekapituliert die man im
hasen mit dem bernstein augen schon
gelesen hat für jemand der nur noch gar
nichts von ihm kennt für den ist kann
man da ganz sicher ein faszinierender
einstieg in diese persönliche und dann
darüber hinaus kulturgeschichte wer den
hasen mit dem bernstein augen gelesen
hat und das haben wir nun erstaunlich
viele menschen da freilich viele
menschen der wird im neuen buch dann
doch ein paar passagen haben wo er denkt
ja das habe ich doch schon gelesen und
vielleicht doch etwas ausführlicher und
damit noch interessanter als bei diesem
sehr sehr schlanken band von knapp 180
seiten wo er noch knapp 40 seiten für
sehr hübsche bebilderung draufgehen und
die briefe selber sind auch recht kurz
das heißt sie hören manchmal am beginn
der zweiten seite auf also das ganze
liest man sehr schnell was ja manchmal
auch sehr schön ist aber vom
inhaltlichen reichtum tritt es ganz
deutlich gegenüber dem gebiet von der
wahl zurück auf die form wollte ich
jetzt eigentlich auch noch mal zu
sprechen kommen nämlich den briefroman
und eben auch die bilder die immer
wieder damit korrespondieren was tut
diese form denn zum text dazu und was
tun die bilder zum text dazu eine
doppelte art von persönlichkeits
schaffung zum einen ist es ein
unmittelbarer monolog der aber natürlich
einen dialog und ein dialogisches
prinzip hat zwischen edmund de waal und
dem ihm ja nun persönlich nicht
bekannten musste kommando durch die form
des an diesen mann gerichtete briefe die
wirken natürlich sehr persönlicher
spricht in unterschiedlicher schirmes
lieber freund herr graf das alles mag
amondo und dementsprechend haben die
briefe ganz unterschiedliche tonlagen je
nachdem was für themen darin
angesprochen werden das ganze wird aber
auch in einer art simulation wie ein
brief nicht eines zeitgenossen aber dann
doch sagen eines standesgenossen
gehalten also man merkt da sind zwei
vertreter großer familien die sich
schreiben und aus diesem
selbstbewusstsein heraus und natürlich
auch mit dem wissen um dieses familiäre
heraus schreibt edmund de waal das ist
sehr reizvoll weil man wirklich das
gefühl hat an dem team briefwechsel wenn
auch zugegebener weise nur von einer
seite geführt zu lesen und er macht es
sehr geschickt man hat manchmal das
gefühl hat sogar antworten bekommen von
hewitt kann man da auch wenn daraufhin
ihre kurs genommen wird aber er versucht
wirklich so etwas wie ein brief gespräch
zu entwickeln was die bilder zum text
beitragen ist für mich allerdings noch
ein bisschen faszinierender es sind
alles bilder bis auf zwei ausnahmen
die aus einem museum zur verfügung
gestellt worden sind nämlich dem museum
bekam mondory come on over der sohn von
moody's jener unglückliche soldat im
ersten weltkrieg davon den deutschen
abgeschossen wurde und darüber war sein
vater natürlich so entsetzt dass ein
einziger sohn und damit prospektierte
nachfolger jetzt nicht mehr am leben war
dass er in seinem haus in dem er lebte
einem fantastischen damals gerade erst
neu errichteten nämlich ganz schnell
fertig gestellten palais in der nähe des
parc monceau in der rue de moz so nichts
mehr verändert hat er hat gesagt so wie
mein sohn das gelesen gesehen hat so war
es für ihn gedacht als sein erbteil
jetzt ist dieser sohn tot an diesem haus
wird nichts mehr verändert und in seinem
testament hat er dieses haus dem
französischen staat geschenkt mit der
maßgabe dass dort nie etwas verändert
werden dürfe das gilt bis heute und
erfreulicherweise ist es auch nicht
während der nazizeit geplündert worden
sehr verblüffend aber der einzige
glückliche umstand dieser jahre und
anscheinend ist edmund de waal auf der
recherche nach seiner eigenen
familiengeschichte natürlich irgendwann
auch mal in diesem museum vorbei
gegangen und hat sich offenkundig in
diese welt die so erhalten ist die das
was er in seiner familie eben nicht mehr
hat denn die fonds haben alles verloren
und sind eben auch extrem ermordet
worden und enteignet worden da hat er
offensichtlich was gefunden wo er sich
wie zu hause fühlt und diese liebe zu
diesem gebäude und dieses gespräch auch
mit dem gebäude das ist der bestandteil
der bilder die hat er ausgewählt das
sind teilweise kunstwerke die dort
stehende sind aber auch schnappschüsse
aus dem aus dem dem interieur sind
historische aufnahmen sind natürlich
ganz viele familien bilder die man dort
sehen kann das heißt dadurch entsteht
dann noch ein gespräch mit diesem haus
und darüber gibt ja auch in diesen
briefen sehr deutlich auskunft was ihn
bei der begehung dieses zeitlich
stillgelegten hauses fasziniert wir
haben es mit einem autor zu tun der
eigentlich einen anderen beruf hatte
einen anderen beruf gelernt hat töpfern
porzellan künstler sie haben es schon
angesprochen
jetzt ist er auch autor man kann
eigentlich sagen jetzt ist er
hauptsächlich autor dafür bekannt
inwieweit befruchten sich denn diese
beiden welten merkt man dem schreiben an
dass da jemand eigentlich mal ganz
praktisch mit händen gearbeitet hat das
würde ich ganz ein deutlich bejahen da
würde ich eine identität zwischen autor
und erzähler unmittelbar wirklich
annehmen denn es gibt so viele
selbstauskünfte die wahl in diesem buch
gibt über seine tätigkeit als
weltberühmter keramik und porzellan
künstler über das die art wie er
installation mit seinen porzellan
objekten herstellt was das bedeutet für
sein geschichtsverständnis was darin
eingegangen ist von seiner eigenen
familiengeschichte und von geschichten
wie der familie kommando es ist ein
extrem persönliches buch in dem man
einiges darüber lernt auch was mit
edmund de waal seit dem hasen mit dem
bernstein augen passiert das was der
ruhm bedeutet hat den dieses buch ihm
verschafft hat dass er aber auch gewisse
missverständnisse am werk sie dass sich
beispielsweise die republik österreich
jetzt ganz stark um die familie bemüht
nachdem de france ist eben zunächst von
odessa nach wien gegangen waren nur ein
teil der familie nach paris weiter zog
aber man sich in paris eigentlich viel
mehr daran diese familie bereit war zu
erinnern als in österreich dass das sich
aber seit dem hasen mit dem bernstein
augen wieder geändert hat das sind sehr
interessante
selbstauskünfte dies aber eben wirklich
kompliziert machen hier von einem roman
zu sprechen in diesem roman ist insofern
nur ein einziges element fiktiv nämlich
dass edmund de waal annimmt dass es
tatsächlich einen brief empfängernamen
suisse der kommando geben kann der aber
eben vor mittlerweile mehr als 70 jahren
gestorben ist werden 80 jahren gestorben
ist und dementsprechend würde ich das
nicht als roman bezeichnen es sind
fiktive briefe die sind niemals an
jemanden geschrieben wurden sie sind
alle konstruiert aber sie wirken sehr
authentisch ich hätte mich nicht
gewundert dass wenn die beiden
herrschaften sich gekannt hätten die
briefe genauso gelautet hätten diese
feine unterscheidung zwischen
autor und erzähler die man bei roman
gemeinhin trifft
lässt sie sich halten in admont ovals
erzählen oder muss man sagen der der
diese briefe schreibt ist der autor ist
der mensch edmund de waal der uns als
verfasser dieser bücher bekannt ist
neben der
thematisierung seiner eigenen kunst und
und gewisser weise auch natürlich der
thematisierung der frage wie sich da
etwas verschoben hat in der 3 der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung ich würde gar
nicht behaupten dass er mehr zeit auf
bücher schreiben verwendet das tut er
glaube ich nicht er schreibt den risiken
abständen die bücher sind jetzt immerhin
so einem abstand von fünf jahren
erschienen zwischendurch gab es noch ein
buch die weiße straße über seine reisen
auf der spur großer porzellan tradition
ist nach china gefahren erst nach
meisten gefahren erst noch sehr heute
fahren was man alles so wild und
dementsprechend sind das dinge die
offensichtlich auch in halbwegs kurzer
zeit entstehen bei kommando kann man dem
nachwort entnehmen dass er da nur ein
paar monate daran geschrieben hat aber
es ist wie gesagt auch ein schmaler band
und hat die ganze zeit über seine
eigentliche profession nämlich die des
bildenden künstlers eben mit keramik und
porzellan objekten weiter beibehalten
hat natürlich durch die bekanntheit als
autor einen ganz anderen ruhm auch in
seiner eigentlichen sparte gefunden also
die ausstellungsplätze wurden immer
prominenter die galerien immer wichtiger
in denen er ausstellte aber es ist nun
nicht so gewesen dass der mann unbekannt
gewesen wäre nur mittlerweile bin ich
ihm in dresden begegnet den staatlichen
kunstsammlungen wo er installationen
gemacht hat im wiener kunsthistorischen
museum in paris sowieso in london in den
wichtigsten museen also dem stehen
tatsächlich durch den erfolg des hasen
mit dem bernstein augen glaube ich alle
türen offen auch in seiner eigentlichen
profession und dass sich das ganze dann
doch thematisch sehr eng führen lässt
das liegt daran dass die wahl immer
schon jemand war der nicht einfach nur
porzellan gefäße beispielsweise
hergestellt hat das hat er getan und die
sehen wunderschön aus aber hat die im
regelfall installiert das heißt er hat
sie nicht als einzelnes mal ein beispiel
zu nennen becher genommen und dann
verkauft sondern hat beispielsweise zehn
oder zwanzig weitgehend identisch
geformte becher hergestellt hat sie in
einen räumlichen kontext gesetzt
beispielsweise eine sehr aufwändig
gestaltete regal landschaft oder hat sie
unter einem parkett in ein loch
eingelassen wo man überhaupt erst durch
ein fenster hindurch gucken muss um zu
sehen dass darunter porzellan ist und
hat mit diesem verschwinden seiner
objekte bezug genommen auf das
verschwinden seiner eigenen familie und
überhaupt des europäischen judentums all
diese dinge sind moralisch ethisch sehr
hoch aufgeladen historisch werden sie
begleitet von von sehr sehr
umfangreichen überlegungen des künstlers
zudem den teilen die man sich dazu auch
wieder denken soll und das macht
natürlich auch wiederum einen großen
teil des erfolgs des bilden dass edmund
de waal aus weil da ein ähnliches
verfahren gewählt wird was er eben auch
in seinen büchern betreibt er
rekonstruiert vergangenheit und weist
auf die leerstellen in der europäischen
geschichte hin jetzt nennt edmund de
waal die route muss so eine straße der
konversationen eine straße der anfänge
was es wohl damit gemeint einmal
natürlich dieses ständige austausch
verhalten zwischen den dort ansässigen
großen familie die rothschilds hatten
auch nicht weit weg in einer nebenstraße
ein riesiges palais das gilt noch für
andere wichtige familien und die waren
eben laufen miteinander im kontakt und
der anfänge insofern als es dort den
versuch gab eine neue art des jüdischen
selbstverständnisses zu schaffen und
auch eine neue art von von
selbstverständlichkeit jüdischen lebens
was vor allem auch eines war was gar
nicht mehr religiös bestimmt war sondern
vor allem kulturell sich definierte als
eben besonders verfeinerte europäische
kultur dass das dort versucht wurde und
wie eben die wahl feststellt leider
gottes auch gescheitert es dort aber
eigentlich leider gottes was überall
gescheitert ist worin er aber immer noch
ein modell sieht für das was heute
wieder not tut nämlich die rückbesinnung
auf kulturelle werte auf das ständigen
gespräch miteinander ich wette der wahl
würde jetzt nicht so weit gehen zu sagen
dafür müssen wir alle multi millionäre
werden was natürlich schön wäre wenn wir
es alle wären aber das ist nicht die
grundvoraussetzung für ihn sondern sagt
die kultiviertheit das interesse an der
vergangenheit die bereitschaft
verschiedene kulturen miteinander ins
gespräch zu bringen und den anderen
gegenüber auch jeweils toleranz walten
zu lassen darin sieht er eine art
modellregion rund um den park toms so
weil er sagt da waren die leute die in
einer bestimmten historischen phase das
glück hatten reich genug dafür zu sein
sich das leisten zu können dieses glück
hatten heute nur noch sehr wenige
menschen aber die werte die sie
vertreten haben die leistungen die sie
erbracht haben dass intensive nachdenken
was sie betrieben haben die liebe zu den
gegenständen und zu ihren familien das
ist natürlich etwas was
dankenswerterweise nicht notwendig an
reichtum gebunden ist und was man
allemal vorbildhaft nennen kann edmund
de waal oder auch der erzähler wir
wissen es nicht genau spricht immer
wieder über sein englisch sein was er
natürlich dann auch im kontrast zum
pariser rischen steht sehr faszinierend
die engländer sind der glaube ich die
nation die ihre eigene nationale
verfasstheit am gründlichsten untersucht
haben in unendlichen
aufsetzen englischen das auf englisch
art und so weiter und
diese tatsächlich sehr sehr besessen mit
ihrer verfasstheit jetzt wie ist dieses
buch jetzt wie kommt der engländer nach
rein
verwandelt er sich das pariser rische an
trägt er es wie ein kostüm kommt er auch
als englischer tourist dort rein oder
ist das ganze eigentlich sowieso eine
eine
kosmopolitische mixtur das ist es ganz
sicher in der absicht jede wahl damit
betreibt das ist glaube ich eine sehr
gute beschreibung wobei die mixtur
natürlich immer einen leicht negativen
beiklang hat nennen wir es eine
kosmopolitische programmen schrift in
den briefen das würde die sache glaube
ich sehr gut treffen aber es ist so dass
man am anfang sofort in diesen
briefwechsel hineingeworfen wird er
schreibt dann kommando und sagt erstmal
sehr wenig über sich und je länger
dieser briefwechsel dauert je weiter wir
er ist streng chronologisch in gewisser
weise aufgebaut das beginnt sozusagen
mit dem mit der konstituierung dieses
palast in paris da wird noch ein
bisschen dessen vorgeschichte erzählt
und dann kommen all die schrecklichen
ereignisse dieses familienleben ins
unglück gestürzt haben und die begleitet
er konnte war mit seinen rundgängen
durchs haus und mit assoziationen die er
dort hat und je mehr er auch das leid
der kommandos in den blick nimmt desto
persönlicher wird er was sein eigenes
ich angeht und desto mehr erfahren wir
über ihn und desto mehr wird auch betont
allerdings wirklich sehr spät erst in
diesem buch das er eben natürlich eine
ganz andere sozialisation hat als all
die franzosen über die er da erzählt und
auch als der franzose mit dem er
korrespondiert nämlich in der tat er ist
in england aufgewachsen seien teil der
familie hatte sich dorthin retten können
und sein großvater war christ seine
großmutter jüdin und die familie ist im
christlichen glauben aufgewachsen das
heißt er ist als protestant erzogen
worden und das war auch schon im hasen
mit dem bernstein augen durchaus ein
thema er fühlt sich durchaus natürlich
ganz stark beeinflusst durch seine
jüdische herkunft aber er kann nicht
davon absehen dass in einem christlichen
umkreis aufgewachsen ist und immer noch
christ ist und da merkt eine art
zwiespalt bei edmund de waal sich auch
immer wieder zeigt er schreibt über die
jüdischen themen er verwandelt sich das
jüdische leben an mehr adaptiert vieles
davon für sein eigenes selbstverständnis
und trotzdem kann er natürlich nie sagen
wir kennen diese probleme aus anderen
derzeit laufenden debatten ich bin
wirklich jude das ist der in dem sinne
eben nicht das weiß er sehr genau das
wird nicht thematisiert im buch aber es
ist hochinteressant wo solche fragen
dann gelesen werden können als eine
sagen wir mal spezifische
auseinandersetzung auch mit sich selbst
und dem eigenen selbstverständnis und
das macht es dann wieder sehr
interessant denn das ist hier in meinen
augen vielleicht auch wenn es auch so
knappem raum passiert intensiver als im
hasen mit dem bernstein augen also hier
das ist ein glaube ich dann doch sogar
persönlicheres buch natürlich auch wegen
dieser absender fiktion die er da ein
geht während der hase mit dem bernstein
augen ein zwar auch aus der ich
perspektive geschrieben das aber sehr
sehr erzählerisches buch ist
erzählerisch iss kommando eigentlich nur
insofern dass man briefe gerne liest
aber nicht dass es da einen schönen
großen zusammenhang gebe die man einfach
so runter lesen kann wie es beim hasen
mit dem bernstein augen empfunden habe
amondo erfordert ein bisschen mehr
mitdenken und manchmal geht es auch über
das ideal da was ich an mitdenken herr
ansetzen würde hinaus wird sehr viel
weiter benjamin zitiertes oder sehr viel
profitiert das liebe ich weil walter
benjamin bin ich natürlich nicht ganz so
begeistert denn das sind dann auch die
etwas na ja sagen wir sehr gestelzte
formulierungen die da so rein kommen
dementsprechend habe ich das gefühl dass
das ist das ganz klar ambitionierteste
buch was er bisher geschrieben hat aber
darum hat es auch ein paar probleme die
die ersten beiden nicht gewusst hat ja
auch ist in der nähe des partners so
aufgewachsen theodor herzl hat in der
rhythmus so gewohnt also durchaus nicht
nur die fugees kampflos und rothschild
das heißt das buch hat die gelegenheit
auch in die gesellschaftsgeschichte also
über die geschichte jüdischen
gesellschaft die da versammelt es hinaus
in die gesellschaftsgeschichte aus
zugreifen nimmt edmund de waal das war
und trägt dieser briefroman diese
auswüchse ich würde nicht behaupten dass
man wirklich ein richtiges
gesellschaftsbild des paris des
fernsehers jäckle oder sagen wir mal bis
in die dreißiger jahre hin ein dass das
der mondänen paris dort geboten bekommt
schon die tatsache dass ich ja vom
gesellschaftsbild des mondänen paris
jetzt gerade gesprochen habe entlarvt
bereits dass sich um ein doch sehr
schmales spektrum handelt und ich mal
das würde ich für ganz eingelöst
erachten wenn man ein buch lesen will
was wirklich auf unglaublich
reichhaltige weise und mit sehr sehr
klugen bemerkungen über die
französischen reichen jüdischen familien
dieser zeit haben möchte dann sollte man
von von james macaulay dass auch in
diesem jahr erschienen der hauser
franchisings lesen das erstaunliche
parallelen natürlich in dem thema damit
edmund de waal hat aber mindestens
doppelt so dick ist und einfach viel
besser recherchiert ist natürlich auch
ein sachbuch ist keiner zählendes buch
da erfährt man die erstaunlichsten dinge
über sagen wir diesen sehr schmalen sehr
exklusiven ausschnitte französischen
gesellschaft aber was nun edmund de waal
ganz sicherlich auch leistet ist
natürlich einmal eine zuspitzung man
braucht eben auch sehr viel weniger zeit
um seine dinge dort zu lesen und
genießen zu können und was ihm dann doch
immer wieder mal gelingt in dem sinne
was sie eben sagten herze leben kommt
nur an einer stelle im buch mal so vor
aber er macht einen wahnsinnig neugierig
auf diese zeit auch auf die militärzeit
das leider gottes eben gestorbenen sohn
ist über die erfährt man auch nicht
wahnsinnig viel man erfährt nur er war
eben flieger dass ich dann auch nicht
selbstverständlich im ersten weltkrieg
gewesen er war absolut überzeugter
patriot musste seinen nutzern vaterland
gegen deutschland verteidigen und dann
wird er abgeschossen man möchte
eigentlich noch mehr wissen wie hat er
sich da gefühlt als sohn eines
multimillionärs so was erfährt man bei
james mconie da wird beispielsweise über
niesen kommando im krieg erzählt und
dadurch ist das ein anderes
gesellschaftsporträt aber muss auch
ehrlich zugeben de waal hat nicht den
anspruch eines gesellschaftsporträts ja
die große frage ist ja bei dem sohn
eigentlich kauf zu einem multimillionär
sein kind nicht aus der kriegs flicht
geht das nicht oder also ist das
sozusagen eine patriotische
selbstverpflichtung jetzt für dieses
land
dem man sich so nah fühlt vielleicht
näher als das land sich einem selbst für
dann einzustehen besser als ich es
gerade getan haben kann man es nicht
formulieren genau so ist es gewesen das
geht sehr deutlich sowohl aus dem was
edmund de waal erzählt hervor als auch
aus dem was ich ansonsten über diese
zeit um diese menschen gelesen habe und
das was man wirklich sehr besuchenswert
museen kommando auch wiederum lernen
kann die haben sich dermaßen als
franzosen begriffen dass der angriff auf
dieses land und jeder fühlte sich einen
ersten weltkrieg angegriffen als versuch
seitens der kommandos unter anderen
reichen familien und überhaupt der juden
in frankreich betrachtet wurde den
emanzipierten staat in europa zu
besiegen und die haben sich wirklich in
einem maße eingesetzt wie die deutschen
juden umgekehrt ganz genauso im ersten
weltkrieg das ist mit noch einer
größeren intensität würde ich behaupten
als die nichtjüdischen deutschen oder
franzosen wenn ich jetzt mit einem buch
anfangen muss von edmund de waal oder
möchte fange ich mit kommandeuren oder
mit dem hasen mit den bernstein augen
der hase mit dem bernstein augen ist das
viel zugänglicher buch darum würde ich
sagen das ist sicherlich ein toller
einstieg aber es macht dann eben die
lektüre von kommando nicht mehr so
interessant wie sie wäre wenn man
darüber noch nichts weiß darum wäre kann
man da natürlich ein fantastischer
versuchsballon wo man dann mal sagt da
habe ich ein dünnes büchlein und ich
kann nach vier oder fünf briefen
ziemlich genau glaube ich sagen ob das
ein stilist es ist auch ein sehr
pathetisches buch muss man nun sagen der
mich mitnimmt in dem ich das gefühl habe
dass mir wirklich etwas ausgesagt wird
über das selbstverständnis einerseits
des autors und über diese diese kleine
elitäre gesellschaft über die er
schreibt und wenn sie das mögen und dann
den hasen mit den bernsteinen augen
danach schieben dann werden sie
plötzlich sehen wie die unglaublich
opulent man auch über diese dinge
erzählen kann mit einem ganz anderen
atem der begriff des atems es ohnehin
wahnsinnig wichtig für das künstlerische
selbstverständnis von edmund de waal und
diese beiden bücher sind tatsächlich wie
einerseits eine ganz kurze atempause
kommando und wie ein ganz schweres
großes atem schöpfen dem hase mit dem
bernstein augen und natürlich denke ich
mal dass mit dem ganz großen atem
schöpfen macht man als vielleicht etwas
vorbereiteter noch ein bisschen lieber
mit und bei dem anderen wenn man das
gefühl hat nein das ist mir zu kurzatmig
gewesen dann kann man es auch lassen so
gesehen vielleicht doch zuerst kommando
jetzt haben sie uns noch einmal
neugierig gemacht auf die bedeutung des
atems im schaffen von edmund de waal er
hatte eine sehr interessante ausführung
zum staub im mühselig amondo weil alles
so wunderbar proper darin ist aber
natürlich feststellt verstaubte dinge
gibt es dort trotzdem und da ist dann
die stelle wo walter benjamin sehr
wichtig wird es gibt von benjamin sehr
faszinierende
textpassagen zum staub und zu rasche und
da hat er auch noch andere dinge parat
was natürlich bei asche sofort wieder
auf die shoah und und all die die
schrecklichen aspekte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts über leitet und das dann
wiederum der atem natürlich wahnsinnig
wichtig wird was über den luftzug diese
dinge wie den staub und den atem bewegt
wieder in bewegung setzt ich glaube dass
ist genau wie edmund de waal sein
eigentliches schreiben begreift er
möchte eine art luftzug ich möchte nicht
von durchlüftung sprechen er ist nicht
heftig in dem wie er schreibt aber er
möchte dinge die sich gesetzt haben und
die wie eine schicht über etwas liegen
wieder in bewegung bringen und damit
einen neuen aggregats zustand herstellen
etwas versuchen etwas überhaupt erst
einmal zeigen indem der staub
weggeblasen wird die asche von von
dingen weggenommen wird und darum ist er
derjenige der über sein schreiben mit
seinem atem diese dinge in bewegung
bringt und darum tauchte atem als
begriff immer wieder auf das hat auch
mit natürlich mit porzellanherstellung
zu tun er ist nun weiß gott viel zu klug
in seinem eigenen metier um nicht zu
wissen wie wichtig kontinuierliche
luftzug für für den heiz prozess in
einem porzellan ofen ist das spielt in
seinem zweiten buch eine wahnsinnig
wichtige rolle da wird man wirklich
eingeführt in die technik der porzellan
bereitung und plötzlich sieht man wie
wahnsinnig ähnlich edmund de waal seine
beiden kunstformen sieht edmund de waal
ska mondo ist ende september bei zsolnay
erschienen wurde übersetzt von brigitte
hintzen sauer hat 192 seiten und kostet
ist aber sehr sehr schön gestaltet 26
euro wir sagen herzlichen dank lieber
andreas platthaus
herzlichen dank an sie
mehr über und auch von edmund de waal
finden sie liebe hörerinnen und hörer in
den schoß verlinkt und auf unserer seite
kath.net / bücher podcast bücher mit
sie erreichen uns unter der
e-mailadresse bücher - podcast der vz
punkt.de bücher auch hier mit sie finden
diesen podcast überall wo es gute
podcasts gibt und bei instagram finden
sie uns als faz bücher auch hier mit uni
wir sagen vielen dank fürs zuhören und
bis bald bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]